- [Mark] All right, Maddie.
Maddie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Maddie] Um, I've grown up
in a couple of different states,
Arizona, Oregon, Wyoming, and here.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a child?
- Um, I didn't have a childhood really.
I was always getting left places
by my biological parents,
so when I was taken from them
foster care and getting
adopted wasn't really good.
And then the adoption
family, (car engine revving)
and I kind of got really on bad terms,
and I came out here.
- [Mark] How'd your
biological parents lose you?
- Um, my mom's a drug
addict and a prostitute.
And then my dad is in prison.
- [Mark] So you went to the
foster system at what age?
- Five.
- [Mark] How was that experience?
- It wasn't good.
I just went to one home.
The first day I went to one home
and then they didn't want us,
so then I went to the next home.
That home ended up adopting
us two years later,
and until I was 12 I lived with them,
before I went to mental health hospitals.
After that I was sent
to live with my brother
'cause he was my only option.
And I didn't know him before
I went to go live with him.
And then I came out here.
- [Mark] How was the time
you spent with your brother?
- It was okay.
It was better than being at
home with the foster parents,
but it wasn't the best,
but it was still better.
- [Mark] Any abuse when you were a kid?
- Yeah, I have had sexual abuse
and physical abuse and emotional abuse.
- [Mark] From the foster parents?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What age was that going on?
- From eight years old
all the way up until I was 15
I was getting abused by the mom.
She'd hit me,
and she'd always say
that she didn't love me
or other stuff.
And the dad, in third grade
he started sexual abuse,
abusing until I was in seventh grade.
- [Mark] And then you went
on your own at what age?
- 15.
- [Mark] Where'd you go?
- Out here.
- [Mark] To LA?
You've been homeless since when?
- June 24, 2019.
- [Mark] So you had a job for awhile?
- No.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 16 and a half.
- [Mark] Oh, you're 16?
You look older.
- Yeah, I get that a lot.
- [Mark] I would not have
guessed you to be 16.
So you have mental health issues as well?
I mean, it's hard not to
with the childhood you had.
- Yeah.
I tried everything possible
to get out of the house,
'cause I couldn't take it anymore.
I couldn't stay there and
keep getting hit or abused.
And it was really starting to weigh on me
so I started cutting myself,
and I overdosed when I was 12.
I had a whole bunch of pills,
like eight, nine different kind of pills,
and social workers in
Oregon didn't do anything
'cause they deemed the house safe.
- [Mark] So did you go
to high school at all?
- Yeah, I went to the first year
of high school, ninth grade,
and I'm a little above ninth grade,
but other than that I
haven't continued back up.
- [Mark] Where do you stay now?
You're in a tent?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Are you using drugs at all?
- Sometimes I do, but I've looked up a lot
and seen a lot of people change on it,
and the new drug, that
fentanyl that came out ages.
I'm starting to slow down,
but sometimes I relapse.
- [Mark] So you're using fentanyl?
- Because I get bored.
Oh no, I don't use fentanyl.
- [Mark] What do you use?
- Most of the time I use crystal,
and I smoke it.
I used to shoot it up, but
I almost died from that.
- [Mark] Are you using any other drugs,
heroin or crack?
- I used heroin one time,
it was not my drug.
And I used crack one time,
but I didn't feel anything from it.
- [Mark] How are you supporting yourself?
What do you do for money now?
- Recycling.
I also have family out here.
And they're not like my blood family,
they're just people I've met out here
who have watched over me
and taking care of me.
- [Mark] Have you had any
bad things happen to you
while you've been down here on skid row?
You seem like you might be a
little more vulnerable target
than most folks.
- Yeah, people, like
just 'cause I'm white,
that makes me a target.
And people are really racist out here.
Even them being adults.
I like, not being rude,
I'm more of an adult than
a lot of people out here
because they like to start drama,
and it's just entertainment for them.
I've been sexually abused out here.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff has happened here?
- Guys touching me in my sleep.
Some guys cumming on me.
I had a boyfriend,
my first boyfriend who
used to me up every day.
- [Mark] Do you find yourself doing things
outside of what you'd
normally allow yourself to do
since you've been down here?
- [Maddie] I think the only
thing is really smoking,
and maybe eating food that
I wouldn't normally eat
on an everyday basis,
but being out here has made
me also become more grown
because I see how people are,
and I did not want to be my
final resting spot out here,
but...
- [Mark] You still have
hope for a better life?
- [Maddie] Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] That's good.
- [Maddie] But I know that the
foster care system is not my,
it's not the right choice for me,
so I know if I could
just push through this
until I could just make it till I'm 18,
and then do online school and
get an SRO and then get a job.
- [Mark] That'd be great.
You know, 'cause you don't
seem to fit down here.
- [Maddie] No.
- You don't seem to be meant for this.
- [Maddie] But at the same time
I have people who make me fit in.
They just support,
they don't like me being down here,
but they always have
my back and everything.
It's a family out here.
- [Mark] Yeah, getting
away from this neighborhood
would probably be a healthy thing for you.
- I, I don't know if I could do that
because of people out here
who I've connected with
who are good for me,
but at the same time that's the only part
that would scare me,
I would never be able to see them again.
- [Mark] Do you feel like this life
on skid row is a good fit for you?
I mean a lot of people feel
like this is their home, eventually.
- It's home.
It is home.
It does grow on you,
but everybody hates it.
The gangbangers, they all hate it,
and they regret going into the gangs,
but they still do it because
once you're in a gang
you can't really go backwards.
And it's really hard,
like there will be days where it rains
and there's no food.
You go five days without food,
soaking wet with no clothes,
but it'll all come to you eventually.
Depends on what your hustle is.
A lot of people hustle,
and they hoe or they sell
drugs or kill people.
It all depends on the person.
- [Mark] When were you
first introduced to drugs?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] When did you first
get introduced to drugs?
- 20, 28, 27th of June last year.
Within the first month
I started shooting up,
and I did two back-to-back
shots and almost died from that.
And that scared me enough
not to do shots anymore.
- [Mark] Are you scared that maybe
if you spend too much time
down here you'll have changed?
- I've changed a lot
since being down here.
I've learned more about myself
and things I didn't like like anger,
but I guess that's a lot about being hurt.
And I do put up with a lot,
like I get a lot of bullying,
and there's a lot of not
fitting in that it doesn't help.
And people are scared because my age,
but I have also changed in a good way too.
I'm just scared that this place is,
they don't want nobody to succeed,
or you usually end up following the crowd,
and I'm afraid that I might die out here
if I'm not strong enough,
or if I do the wrong mistake on accident
because I'm mad or something.
But other than that,
I'm not really afraid of being out here.
- [Mark] Are you afraid of
maybe a changing your personality?
You know, your values might change
by being down here over time.
- To a certain point-
- [Mark] You might become
a harder, tougher version
of the softer, kinder
girl that you once were.
- Yeah, to a certain point yes,
but also it has opened my eyes
because the world is a very cruel place.
Everywhere is different,
but it's also teaching me a lot
to see right through
the bull shit of people,
and lying and ulterior
motives that people have,
'cause a lot of people tell you something
to tell you it to get what they want
out of the situation instead
of what is best for you,
and the saying that you are born alone
and you die alone is very true,
but you can't live life alone.
You can't also rely on everybody a lot.
- [Mark] All right, Maddie,
well thank you for coming in
and talking with me.
Good luck with getting out of skid row
and getting your life together.
It would be really nice to see you
find somebody that
takes you away from here
and get your life back on track.
- [Maddie] If there was a
chance I could get schooling
and still be out here and
my SRO and a job legally,
I'd do all of it,
but just live on my own
so I could get a real apartment
instead of an SRO.
- [Mark] All right,
Maddie, well good luck.
I wish the best for you.
- Thank you.